durante una presentación de casi tres
horas ante el congreso de perú y do
bellido primer ministro de este país
expuso el plan de gobierno del
presidente pedro castillo y pidió el
voto de confianza al parlamento en su
discurso de guido aseguró que los
principales lineamientos del gobierno
son derrotar la pandemia del cob y 19 y
reactivar la economía para esta
finalidad adelantó que solicitará
legislativo la delegación de facultades
en materia tributaria y en salud para
reformar el sistema sanitario y la
seguridad social pedido también aseguró
que perú se encuentra en negociaciones
con diversos laboratorios para adquirir
89 millones de vacunas contra el cob y
19 en el 2022 el primer ministro de los
peruanos señaló que además se enfocará
en la lucha contra la corrupción y le
pidió al parlamento aprobar en conjunto
una legislación que imponga cadena
perpetua para personas sancionadas por
corrupción para conseguir el respaldo
político
bellido necesita 66 votos del parlamento
la posición de los congresistas es
dividida uno se inclinan por otorgar el
voto de confianza y luego presionar para
cambiar algunos ministros otros sanz
otorgar la investidura porque señala que
en el gabinete de bellido existen
ministros con investigaciones por
terrorismo existen legisladores que se
inclinan por votar y en abstención la
decisión de los congresistas se sabrá
tras un largo debate que podría culminar
esta noche o mañana